citizens of the reject Nation it is time to watch
dread neither of us have seen we did just watch
Judge Dredd we had a very particular time with
if you didn't watch that go check that out it's
available right now I had a good time with it
he had a good time with it but both acknowledged
boy oh boy was that not the best of movies we've
heard this one is however so please leave a like
on this video so we know that you liked the good
dread because we hear it's great now I'm excited
to watch more action movies let us know in the
comments what action movie you think we should
watch next because we're very excited to do
so and speaking of wonderful sexy rejects the
patrons get this whole shebang they can watch not
just our resting faces but our resting dread faces
so head on over to patreon and become a
super sexy reject and you can watch this
front to back beginning to end without
gaps in its entirety without further Ado
it's time to Grimace it's time to see what
justice prevails it's time to judge dredge
oh America is an irradiated Wasteland
within Eliza City cool that's
the cursed Earth inside the walls the cursed
City so searching from Boston to Washington DC
an unbroken concrete landscape 800 million people
living in the ruin of the old world how it feels
like like Dread the emotion immediate red
yeah and I love that there's no flavor to
the architecture it's just blue yeah I know
it's grounded Mega City one awesome convulsing
choking breaking under its own weight I think
I better love this movie koi very happy so far
I'm fighting for order in the chaos what
cool production do men and women of the
Hall of Justice Stark but interesting yeah make it
realistic more real grounded juries executioners
judges
it's like they use real City
shots and then they impose VFX
over it and they added like cloned
buildings to make it look neutral
and vehicles sector 13. it's got goosebumps
suspects are under the influence
of Narcotics that bike is awesome
are they doing illegal substances those are
drugs that are fake YouTube it is not real
that is visually stunning yeah
this looks really appealing
I said we got a judge there
too think of everything I am
oh
I like how that van looks smelly
the entire atmosphere feels very
palpable yeah the production
design is gorgeous on this
oh my God I love it I love how real
situation that was oh just perps just
wiped out of medicine I'm taking him down
a reason for the escalation unlike Stallone
yes what a shot
charge their asses judge
judge oh they're judged he judged the hell out of
them control paramedics to my GPS multiple wounded
and bodies for recycling it's like a Dawn of the
Dead Vibe about this right oh that's a good call
release the hostage unharmed and I guarantee you
a sense of life in an ISO cube without parole oh
he's negotiating what is this this isn't my dread
you want a very good negotiator judge you
got no elaborate beverages your life dumbass
negotiations over here I'll kill a
[__] yeah I heard your hot shot
wow
holy shot oh this is microwave that guy's
face this feels like when someone makes a
great fan film it feels like a student film
but like but one of those like great ones you
catch on YouTube they're like this should
be a feature they did it yeah Cassandra
Anderson 21 born in a block 100 meters from
the radiation boundary wall at age seven she
lost both parents to residual Fallout cancer
as is usual with orphan she was given a judge
aptitude test at age nine I care about
her now how many people are observing you
two what can you tell me about the
person I'm with what just happened
she has powers well another judge
oh she's a psychic I can feel anger
control empath psychic the radiation I want
you to take her out give her one day in the
field supervised see if she makes a grade
chuck her in the deep end it's all a deep end
District 9 also had that why doesn't
everyone make movies like this
is that Lena Heady yeah yeah
I heard she was in this oh
that is awesome that is really gorgeous
what is this fake drug that slows down everything
and sparkles it we got trouble they were selling
Stern Hammer product On My Level I run them
off with a beaten a couple of weeks ago oh
I love this guy yeah me too he looks like Luke
Cage right now chain yellow black jacket okay
are they gonna show that I don't know if I want
to see that hit him with a little slow-mo first
is that what it's called they're gonna make him
feel it for longer oh that's so
evil like wait the ramifications
oh that's so evil
holy crap oh so he lives the fall longer oh
are they gonna do that how does that even work
because your body is actually I don't understand
your perception of time is altered unlike many but
if you fall your body would hit the ground before
you know what I mean but your perception would
be slower on the journey so like time is relative
there's so many and they skinned them and then
tossed 12 serious crimes reported every minute 17
000 per day we can respond to around six
percent which six percent your show rookie
you tell me peach trees Multiple homicide
Droid to control we'll take peach trees
okay this one actually feels like an anti-hero
yeah versus Stallone she's just like unhinged
just murderous yeah judgment vagrancy three
weeks ISO tubes but prioritize murders correct
but prioritize murders
ew damn makeup in this movie huh it's a Coburn
from a slow-mo inhaler only just hit the grid but
it's making big waves I love the title of that
slow Mouse guess it felt like a long way down
wild that is haunting
drugging someone so they suffer more is so messed
up it's gonna be like okay yeah people said it
was I remember like many years ago people say
it was like die hard uh because going up oh is
it one place I mean they're here now they're
going up the building yeah sorry for Rooney
I heard that too it's all right immediately
I think it's a punishment killing someone's
trying to send a message don't with the mama
Clan the mama client we have her on record
for most days Madeline Magica that's her AKA
Mama ah clever I'll trade markers and violence
Jesus I love how gory this is so intense
the victims are registered to apartments
on level 39 so purpose will be in
the vicinity find out where the clan
operate on this level and hit it hard
what a great Exposition tool you just
learned about this Empire they're like
we're taking them down right now guitars
wondering when you'd remember you left your
helmet behind sir a helmet can interfere with
my psychic abilities like Magneto think
a bullet might interfere with some more
you ready yes sir you don't look ready
just adrenaline sir I love the weird
pairing of these two yeah they're great
cool
gnarly how did they shoot this is it on like a
phantom that's then slowed and lit different yeah
oh I love it
dude icky what beautiful violence such
beautiful violence oh look at the mirror shot
requesting meat wagon to peachtree's level 39 we
have four bodies for recycling and eight live for
the iso cubes let's get them cuffed move it's cool
that's a recycle The Dread is the constant and
then she's gonna be the one on the character Arc
yeah yeah and the exposition that comes from it
why
don't even give you time to look away
saved me a lot of paperwork
if you just confess right now
download Gleason I think you're right yeah yeah
this would be super early Domino Gleason touch it
no no no no no uh Caleb there's a problem on
level 39. or is it the guy from Cabin in the Woods
Frank Kranz yeah I don't know I think
it's Dominic redhead racist if they're
taking him in he'll talk what are we gonna
do we're gonna take back King's Landing whoa
that was sick cybernetic enhancements
hacker man hacking ghosts
two I see why people want to sequel to this
control room is secure yeah I'm trying
to find things to criticize to make sure
people know we're not promoting jack
[__] on this channel oh well this
movie that didn't get a sequel that didn't do well
I just want to check you were notified about
the Defcon systems test today if you check the
uh I've got nothing we are good to go right now
I've got my supervisor breathing down my neck
wow she is intimidating yeah how did all emergency
services are notified to ignore you can run
like she didn't even have to do like wow she's
so cold so he's thinking about
making a move for your gun yeah
he just changed his mind yep
really good humor here
that doesn't sound good
flood smear warrant ya get up
you're headed for the cubes doors
oh
you know if that homeless guy wasn't there they
could have walked out those doors by now yep
damn the DP for this movie just did
such a great job yeah I wonder what
else they did this is so good you're patched in
I am the Lord
that's his cameo focusingly somewhere in
this block are two judges I want them dead
until I get what I want the block is locked down
I'll Clan every level not the judges Town everyone
else clear the corridors and stay the out of our
way until the shooting stops I love how there's
like a soft coldness in her voice Mama it's like
a posturing sympathetic patriarchy of like malice
yeah that's so good you're on assessment rookie
call it man I want warm Target's obstructed line
of sight gas grenades respirators I love the
respect she still shows yeah it's like a short
assessment I'd be like we're about to talk to hell
with this assessment that's how bad every day is
foreign
you got five thanks for the heads up
oh excellent excellent a flash grenade
in this world what are you waiting for
rookie his crime is attempted murder
of a judge the sentence is death yes
isn't his head like oof
it's so hard to see someone's thoughts
than end them yeah and I like how you
didn't cut to what his thoughts were you
just felt watched it with the acting yeah
oh that's great great choice
you don't want to snitch on them they'll come
shooting up that place that's so clever secured
the woman somewhere she can't raise any alarms
uh we can't she has a baby asleep in the Next
Room they're a father it's out there looking for
us oh my God I'm not raising any alarms if the men
out there don't know where you are you won't be
killing them there's a service elevator near here
the sun Genesis broken but it's so it's script
is so good it's been going to pay your Riders
it works as long as you're hitting a button above
level 75. I just want you off my level away from
my family it's so realistic makes so much sense
ah what an efficient way to make it like even more
personal and then make the choices make sense
yeah God and they just up the stakes for every
civilian they made every death more impactful it's
so good you meet one family so you've met them all
so genius it was like such an efficient
way oh and it was the guy she killed yeah
oh man
[__] full lockdown they're
going nowhere I tried to do
this clean but they wouldn't
let me so now we do it messy
foreign Lobby whole position behind the Elevator
Shaft to be a good place to defend if I don't come
back and you get cornered you might not want to
get taken alive that is good that's true yeah
I heard about your kind kind of hard to believe
it's real like what am I thinking about right now
oh my God I'm picturing a violent
sexual liaison between the two of
us in a pointless attempt to shock me
but I wasn't trying to shock you if I
was trying to shock you out of it thinking
about this what I'm thinking about now huh
God I love how ugly this world
is but it's so gorgeous real fire
God damn
yeah a lot of people kill judge her
just standing next to these turrets
oh [__] get back
this is a little excessive I like
that you actually feel the stakes
even though we know they have to make it yeah
cool clever that gun has good voice isolation
recognition and all that gunfire stuff yeah
oh I love the word with people we met is great
but they're at the top of the building
this skatepark is here to catch up
there on the ground floor oh no no
39th or whatever yeah yeah okay that was
clever they established how high up this is
calms it back on control do you copy oh Gods
man if they come for us we've got nowhere to go
good advice thanks lady
also effective
I love how ominous of a figure is your gang
locks down the whole block Massacre is an
entire quadrant of men and women and
children just to take out two judges
she's afraid of what you might say and
that's got me curious damn do you have
sharp teeth yes yeah what did they do
to make those look like that yeah you
are so good at acting with his mouth it
is one of the actors instruments coming
yes yes but like they've taken away all of
his other instruments it's very impressive
welcome to the inside of
your head do what I like sure
oh man I figured that would shut
you up hey I can play mind games too
all right oh that flush moment the way
they capture that footage looks like a
snuff film that was unpleasant peach trees is the
manufacturing base for all the slo-mo in mega City
one mom was controlling the production
and distribution across the whole city
interesting stand right here right by this flag
judgment open the blast door right now we've had
a software malfunction and I've lost control of
the system you better get control fast thank you
so terrifying it's like she knows getting him to
be afraid gets him to think faster keep moving and
attempt to avoid further detection or find a place
to defend what about we attack is that an option
well she's guilty we're judges
I've ever seen a movie where like
a building is a city it's so cool
man the way they play with like the
different lenses and cameras so neat freeze
why I'll shoot you with the safety on it isn't
how do you want it kids body bags or chief cubes
very different Stallone Stallone would
have murdered them right in the face
sucks they really need that guy alive
yeah why wouldn't they kill him now
they know everything because they still need a
confession and [__] yeah for the law you're
so you can't like infiltrate his mind right
now bring Xavier yeah right let's break his
mind maybe because she's under duress and
it takes concentration I'm assuming yeah
Carl Irvin must have stood in the mirror
for so long going how can I communicate
emotions now then what am I gonna do
with you you're going to do nothing
you let yourself get taken like
the dumb [__] you are but um
you dead man if you let him talk I
can trace which terminal he's using
you'll know exactly where he
is inhabitants of peach trees
do you think he'll say I am
the law I hope at the end
of the same rules
I am the law yeah
it was like second place it might happen
struck me in carrying out my duty will be treated
as an accessory to our crimes and as for you Mama
judgment time he's only 10 levels
below a South quad balcony terminal 5.
they got him yep he's dead obviously
it's not him
incendiary
yes
God the way they take advantage
of the reflection in his visor
such good work all the over the shoulders
are amazing too usually it does not work
they've done like five of them they're all
great we're gonna stop this guy call 9-1-1
I really love the way Lena Heady plays
the role like it really could have been
a cliche performance yeah but she brings
some like messed up depth dude it's like
dude you can feel a past with her
she's she's terrified yeah you're
standing outside clock's on the lockdown not
function with their defense system open up now
oh well they're all dead yep judge Dead
Two judges trigger Turf War judges die
in Pursuit Of Duty and the purpose who killed
the judges laid out here sounds right excuse me
oh she owns these cops this killing's
all about One gang the mama Clan I'd
say at least one of your two judges are still
alive you're prepared to justify to them sure
oh dread's gonna have to kill these
judges judge the judges oh who judges
the judges who influences the influence Trey
who watches the Watchman one million credits
you have a problem with the
church you know who he is no
I do one million that's Rico third act introduced
I was cloned for others very good twist where's
the other one the rookie we got her here alive
make her dead if you're gonna be a judge we gotta
talk like this I have good lip control that's
part of the qualifications to becoming a judge
It's the final test that's what Olivia thoroughly
didn't pass he still is a nice voice a lot of the
women with helmets don't talk for a reason
those three points are voice based thank you
oh my God he runs low on bullets Stakes
see like a lot of yellow lighting I think
it's meant to symbolize it I I have noticed
a bit of it it also it makes me think of like
a smell like yellow is always like piss rot or
piss like acrid yeah like a basement yes it's
no purple and green I'll tell you that much
foreign
I wonder if this was shot on like HD film if
there's such a thing extra print quality film I
it's digital this thing is incredible everything
it looks like film and at times you could tell the
HD camera yeah it feels like like a red dragon or
something like finchery though identify yourself
dread sector 13. responding to a 10-24
he doesn't know what's up too long negative
three-man Squad closing on my Vector right now two
of us called in the 1024. wondering why you didn't
ask about the other one let's move it I was smart
choke on it red
ouch oh
oh
oh my God he oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
this movie makes me feel sick I hope Fred
cries he refused to stand for something
you betrayed the law You Were Meant to judge now
this I always wanted one of these this is you got
any last words [__] yeah the Titans Remember the
Titans that's funny I was going to ask you that
let's see it
I rare from the first movie and they
were like we had prior Exposition yeah
I've got the girl cold I see her first I shoot her
she sees me first she hesitates then I shoot her
I bet these judges are stunt
performers they have that energy yeah
Tribe Called Quest
oh my God refill or is that just all slow mo I
think it's on Slumber but the gold cap so that was
bullets yeah Universal bullets just what I need in
this video what's the price of a judge these days
million split four ways three ways now
doesn't sound like much to
portray the law betray the city
scumbags rapid fire damn it oh Cindy
Harry armor piercing I love this
two-way split
few out and just run out of bullets
can a judge grab another judge's gun I think
it's their ID because then they can it has to
be framed somebody else okay yeah yeah like how
Rico framed exactly because the DNA because he
was a clone we watched the first one I'm
your backup psychic with the helmet okay
I don't know it only blocks her like it's an
output okay not like magnitude on the piercing
that was a well done reaction
moment I did not expect this
wait Judge Dredd is he judged red he don't
beg finally gets on the wrong end of a gun
what he says is weight buying
time I mean wait for what
wait for me to change my mind wait for another two
or three seconds of life because you're so [__]
weak you just can't stand to see it end I had to
say was waiting this guy's coming with his ego
foreign
becomes a predator
I love like the scuzziness and the sweat yeah
this movie must have flopped hard to not get
a sequel yeah people are clamoring Forks
it's great this is awesome yeah it's so
like tactile it's so bushy ready yeah you look
ready haha that's a good callback I like that
this movie's very viscous
it's just wetly
yes
squeal Pig Mama's in her private choirs
but it's behind ten inches of Steel so
you can't get in there without keypad
combination I I I can give that to you
he's a victim get out of here betting
a felon is not just a fail offense it's
a crime he's a victim not a perp and
until my assessment is formally over
I'm still entitled to dispense Justice
and that's what I just did I love you
you are the law
by law I heard answers Mrs dread awesome
great greatest of the shots oh man
and this training you just see like
the co-working because their training is genius
it's just got that icky cyberpunk
Vibe yeah [__] love it man
oh she like magnetized the room I guess so
you think I didn't know I get busted someday
it goes with the territory this entire level
is rigged with enough High explosives
to take out the top 50 stories oh God
it's a transmitter sink to my heartbeat my
heart stops beating the building blows put
your gun down if he hits her with slow
milk could he could get her out of there
yeah how was how is he gonna have no idea
what are the next moments yeah you're right
we're a kilometer above ground what do
you think of the ranges on that thing
gotta get through 100 levels of
concrete how about 200. let's find out
oh and he threw that guy off the building
in front of her yeah it was like a warning
sign your crimes are Multiple homicide and
the manufacturing distribution of Narcotics
how do you plead all right defense noted
oh my God he's a smashed her through it
that's neat the beginning of the movie you see
her do this yeah but this time you're gonna see it
in her POV yeah where they save the POV for this
and then you see all the Carnage she caused yeah
there's something strangely tragic about all this
oh my God do I want to watch
this I don't know yet I don't oh
ground POV they made us the Splat
I love Gore and sometimes I'm like
I don't know if I want to look at it it's a lot
yeah yeah
so the guy just shot her right
there was no magnets my brain
just went like how did she get
shot I guess that's the case
the depiction of Mama's backstory
reminds me of real life criminals
of heard of like Kingpin women
who like yeah you know turned
that into their own pain and put it
back out your assessment's now over
you did okay
you didn't want to be a judge in
the end so what happened in there
looked like you've been through it perhaps were
uncooperative so how does she do she's a pass
if she wants it tune in to the movie that should
have gotten made dread too 800 million people
living in the ruin of the old world only one
thing fighting for order in the chaos judges
yeah brilliant they credited the creators
of Judge Judd first before anybody yeah
much like the first one it loved the
comic which I respect that's incredible
that was brilliant I've never
seen that in a Credit First
Pete Travis who are you I love you Alex Garland
oh wait I I remember hearing the story behind
this is Alex Garland There's issues that happen
with the directing and Alex Garland pretty much
was the one who actually ended up really directing
this movie one of those cases where it was like I
forget what I remember hearing that forever ago um
but yeah this was like really Alex Garland I mean
he's one of my favorite directors workings that
makes a lot of sense yeah a lot of the visuals but
that also makes sense why I never saw a directed
like yeah I've looked at his filmography 100 times
I've never seen directed my everyone knows that he
pretty much directed this one oh it is incredible
man I was cool the one of the script was so good
yeah Alice Garland Jesus that was incredible I
mean I I feel like we pretty much are commentary
alone pretty much uh said what we felt a lot of
what we would say and the review portion of this
it was just an hour and a half review um but yeah
the in that respect to Carl Urban for not taking
his mask off the entire time not a single that was
the least uh like Diva like he didn't at any point
need to be like I'm Karl Urban under here yeah
you wouldn't never if I didn't know it was Carl
Urban I probably would have been like who is this
guy underneath or or if I'm not plugged into the
industry if I'm just a person that watches movies
I would have been like man a stunt guy finally
got his break yeah I mean even if I hate concept
artist jock that's what I was talking about last
week they gave him credit awesome hell yeah I mean
even if as someone who is pretty much plugged in I
still would not have guessed I was Carl I wouldn't
have guessed that was Carl Urban basically what
I'm getting at I mean like I have no idea who that
is underneath the mask and I love it proven Batman
is possible yeah I know that was awesome that was
so good he had to do a lot with just he literally
just scowled his way through an hour and a half
Matt what could I he must have looked I wonder if
he did what happened he did if he didn't have the
mask on how silly he might actually was because he
probably had to kind of do it a little extra was
there one other judge that shot him through the
back like literally did so much big mouth acting
he was doing the like lips out but it was great
because it worked yeah man I loved it uh this is
like one of my favorite action movies I think this
is one of the I think my favorite films I think
we've covered here yeah on the channel yeah like
that was Sensational it was wildly impressive it
was very tight it was not it was like the perfect
run time for this story didn't feel too short
didn't feel too long I cared about everybody and
it didn't feel overdone overcooked the dialogue
was that 80s dialogue I love but a little bit more
you know aged up to today but the singers were
there yeah nice pulp to it the you calling the I
am the law right what is about to happen maybe so
happens I was really happy he's coming I'm glad
we watched the first one first because I would
yeah I would not have enjoyed watching that next
oh my God can you imagine you know what I mean oh
that would have been a nightmare but we got cool
moments like the gun we got the the background
yeah but we got cool like Throwbacks with the the
lines of dialogue some of the World building but
we also got like watching it first the robot which
we loved and things that I might not have enjoyed
as much if I'd see this version been like what
are we doing so I'm really glad we watched the
first one first but this may be one of the best
remakes that's not a remake continuations it's
just it's not quite a scene like you wouldn't
call it Batman Begins a remake of the Batman
that's true you know one of the best redo
adaptations yeah because it really has to
be a category yeah what is this yeah because
it's not a reboot really I guess kinda anyway
incredible uh Johannesburg so it did have some
District 9 flavor oh okay that makes a lot of
sense yeah so this like this is everything I love
about action movies with a certain budget range
that I want them to make more of and I really wish
it did better because I want another one of these
the one thing oh yeah I was trying
to say uh yeah the one thing
that I kind of craved was a tiny bit I think it
would have just been the one thing to really add
an extra element to it was I never really feared
for dread that normally that is a major hindrance
for me in an experience like this and it wasn't
here I think that would have just been the next
extra bit of propulsion for me be because like a
bit of that John wickness yeah you know where he's
like he's really [__] struggling you know like
even though you know he's gonna be fine yeah you
know John work's gonna be fine a big part of the
selling point is like he's just like really having
a push through and then for something that is even
referencing the plot of Die Hard John McLean oh
he's pushing through pushing through and he made
he had like one moment here where he was going up
against the judges and he gets shot but you know
he heals up pretty fast after that I thought in
that moment he might actually die oh really I
was like maybe she becomes the dread like for
a moment I was like I wonder if she's like you
are the law like I thought we'd like this is
what culture root again oh yeah that was like he
hands in the helmet they ruined the whole thing
it was a brief moment but it was like three
seconds I really was like what's going on yeah
it's like it's like uh what's it called Lord of
the Rings crawler but looking handsome yeah uh but
yeah I I didn't once one of the most impressive
things to me is I now see Carl Urban so much as
Butcher and at no point did I think of that during
this well the dude's got a range man remember him
Star Trek oh no he's incredible bones is so funny
but like I've been watching the boys a lot like
that's been hours of my life and I haven't watched
a lot of curl Urban like since because he's been
playing it so long I was so afraid I'd hear the
gravel I'd see the grittiness and I'd be like oh
it's butcher with a helmet nope now and it's
pretty cool how he can play that that action
here the the rough voice yeah delivery Action Hero
uh but still feel like he brought something out
he brought something different to it yeah it was
like a different anti-hero gritty like it was all
the pieces that could a lesser actor could have
made similar yeah yeah that's kind of how I felt
about all the characters you know right down to
Lena Heady man Lena Heady especially you know I
I love some good True Crime docs and she reminds
me of a lot of those real life people who had like
abusive ass pass as I established here and then
convert that pain into power and criminal under
really criminal lifestyle it doesn't go well get
revenge on society I thought she really brought a
realism to this larger than life scenario they all
did a cold mercilessness that felt like she had
gone through it to get to that point like there
was a weight and a history to her performance
and I love the dynamic between you know because
that is a typical Dynamic Men In Black has it
experienced senior agent and rookie agent right
right like there's it's a it's a it's a it's a
common trait Dynamic for sort of movies and I
and I thought that instead of like let's make
one really colorful personality I want a straight
shooter or something they they managed to keep it
just so in tune with the world and give very
specific portraits to these two characters
without trying to like how do we make this more
fun or Punchy yeah they've found ways to make it
more engaging and fun and I like the chemistry
between them but it never relied on a cliche
sense of chemistry at any point A lot of it was
done in a very laconic way like they did so much
without having to explain but you could pick up on
it yeah they trusted the audience a lot and that's
one thing I talk about a lot of movies I love is
when they trust the audience and I really love
that scene when she saves the judges because she
wants them off her floor like that that scene with
the the one family we meet saves so much time and
there's so much where it could just be like if you
live here you're bad and they didn't do that
which I love and it's for a comic book movie
talk about a visual experience that that
relies not just on a visual experience but
visual storytelling I feel like I I like I I can
I like Zack Snyder films more than you generally
uh like my love for my Affinity for them yeah
a little bit higher a little stronger yeah yeah
um but I did feel I didn't when I did have certain
points I mean just just take for example the use
of the of the drug slow-mo yeah it's more it's
better it's like a lot of it was like this kind
of feels like those Zack Snyder visuals but that
are just it was fun yeah like yeah because like
why would that happen as often a lot of the crazy
visuals that they would choose of how to mix it up
felt within the scene and within the storytelling
you know it was like the third shooter it was like
they're Reinventing another shootout like there
kept being moments where they they had a shootout
and then five minutes let there be another one
but it was a completely different Dynamic but
it didn't feel like a different movie it also
still felt like the same stunt style and the
same action that someone trained in a way would
do but they shot it so differently that I was
like more different yeah it just stayed exciting
this was exceptional the locked off shots the povs
like the moment with the flash grenade yeah um
it reinvented a lot of cool action much the way
that like Jason Bourne showed you could do like a
fight differently or a stunt Chase Card something
differently this did that with like gunfu without
it being gon Fu it did a lot of new element with
shootouts yeah it sucks you into the I love a good
like ugly dystopian beautifulness to that yeah and
I think this really manages to capture that like
it felt immersive it was gorgeous a lot of the
time it feels like an observation piece I felt
truly immersed into this it smelled yeah I kept
talking about the smell it's the one sensory thing
where you're like wow I could I feel like that
I can taste this in some way yeah like have you
ever traveled somewhere that is in a rough way the
thing you noticed I noticed first is the smell and
then that immediately turns into a lack of touch
and that immediately turns into like a sense of
apprehension like for me the smell starts it and I
felt that watching this which is of great success
to a 2d experience I'm sitting in a very nice
place and the whole time I was like I feel sticky
like and I love that if it even the cyberpunk type
score that they had here if it would feel like it
it could be playing in the building yeah you know
yeah like over the the yeah yeah it didn't just
feel like the score for the movie it felt like
this could be coming from the speakers within the
building and it wasn't distracting when there was
like sensory overload in a bad Road it's what I
mean yeah then more yeah I think if they did it
today they could probably enhance some of the
gun play yeah yeah it's I mean it's still it's
still really cool and I love the gore I love the
violence and it was so sweet it was squeamish I
got nauseous twice sometimes a little cartoony
but I think it would help that allowed for it
yeah it allows for some of those slow-mo shots
and everyone was like so good at sounds like a
dumb note they were just so good at acting yeah
but there was no like weak link like I love Domino
I loved that the supporting characters got their
little moments but nobody who had the like no more
Dead Cops like there was no one ruiner of the tone
yeah they managed to invert a lot of tropes with
like a lot of these characters are art types that
you would probably predict would be in this story
like this like the guy like the hacker for the
security system but I love how the background of
him was a a truly someone who was taken advantage
of like and we've got to love her more because of
that I love that they gave us a moment of
redemption for Olivia because we you know
we're following this this girl that's in duress
and so empathetic and they give her the arc that
we need someone to have as an eye line it's such
a great compliment Elementary type of character to
just dread yeah in a movie called dread yeah for a
guy who is so and I and I love the aptness of that
where you do feel like yeah the character is dread
but the movie is such a dread heavy tone yeah
um I'm so impressed but it's not like a slog
or slug dread is usually like the the emotion
of it feels like really slow and very deliberate
within five minutes we were like yeah well this
takes its time the dread is so palpable I love
it um man great sense of atmosphere throughout
but I love the Dynamics and yeah the hacker guy
Lena Heady even the usage red everyone had a good
a great inverse of it even um even what is that
actor's name he's in Creed and Remember the Titans
um the dude who was like oh the the Luke yeah
yeah yeah I didn't catch his name on the credit
side of his name he's fantastic he was so good
at I hated him and I usually love him and he's
such a great actor uh generally and even that
character is another one that would have just
been a cliche sleazy guy who probably mouths off
the most generic shirt right I'm like man they
even bring a lot of difference to him I I guess
though when everyone was recommending this movie
the last thing I was expecting was to be walking
away going the writing of this is so good yeah
I was like I'm gonna have fun it's gonna be an
action movie that's all I thought it was going to
be and like like the one I think we really enjoyed
recently was extraction I had a great experience
but I'd never be like you know the writing an
extreme not expect that to be the takeaway today
of like this is such a taut and tightly written
Thriller I'm so impressed like I'm definitely
gonna recommend this to everyone because I wish
there was another one and when you got in day and
age where uh writers are fighting for something
and actors are fighting for something this shows
what you can this shows you why you got to pay
them well because God damn Alex Garland writing
in the acting is phenomenal in this film I'd
love if more writers got the reputation that
actors get for like the consistency of their work
and Alex Garland is absolutely one of them like
when I when I hear Alex Garland to go yes please
and when writers can make things like this I mean
he did ex machina he did what did he do right
after Xbox I know yes Annihilation right now
he's got a show devs uh devs is a show right now
with Nick Offerman Saturday 24. uh I believe so
um but yeah that's an option here oh yeah we
should add on to the list I would love that I also
haven't seen Desmond if that's a24 probably not
but uh I can say that uh Annihilation is another
great use of sound uh like the annihilation have
you seen Annihilation yeah the way they manipulate
sound to make you like physically uncomfortable
well Natalie Portman's going through some of her
like disorientation I got some of that here well
I think this was the first one he like ever was a
part of I imagine that he directed yeah it sucks
so much because well it's it's kind of akin to uh
Bohemian Rhapsody right there was actually There's
an actual like guy who like oh this guy's really
directed right back in his movie yeah Brian Singer
did it you know and especially for an Oscar movie
like that what a bummer what a hard thing to
watch happen yeah yeah and like I actually the
only thing that made this possible to watch it
here to react with you is had I seen directed
by Oscar I would have seen this yeah so like the
one one good thing is because I never knew it was
Alex Garland I didn't catch it because man that
was Sensational that was Sensational all fronts
man that was great that was fantastic that was a
clean four and a half stars for me like I really
loved that which is a nine to nine point five for
for the 10 scaler yeah yeah that was so good yeah
that was amazing I'm tired now I can't believe we
don't have a sequel I'm so upset I mean it must
have flopped hard I can't even imagine because it
was so good I also I just got a seven point on an
IMDb and that's just not I think Judge Dredd
probably had such a negative effect on it yeah
because it wasn't and Carl Urban wasn't exactly a
I was even now like he's more of a household name
now than before but yeah the boys might be the
only way we ever get drafted to 2012 Carl Urban
who's like post Lord of the Rings yeah what else
did he not at that point yeah there's not really
ahead he was probably the biggest name yeah at
the time and I think Olivia thank you probably
was because of Juno it's probably they kept
her helmet off yeah yeah all right show her
yeah because this was just relying on the
IP of dread which which is 2012 was like
um that was the year of comic book movies oh this
is the year Avengers came out this Avengers yeah
it's one of those I got whatever the year the
Hellboy reboot came out this is like that this
is that it's got lost in the shuffle but it's
also rated R which didn't help it exactly yeah
I do Wonder now if I mean the cult fan base around
this specific film is going on it's just like a
Kickstarter raised to a million dollars [__]
Yeah man they should really try to get this
going who knows who knows who knows maybe we'll
we'll we can speak in the universe by liking and
commenting on this video close it out all right
we are gonna do another action movie very very
soon please comment below what you want us to
watch because I've been enjoying the hell out
of this journey uh please do like subscribe and
all those fun YouTube Shenanigans and share this
unlike you shared your love for dread when it
was in theaters because clearly you didn't uh
but yeah I love the hell out of this uh these
are always fun I love watching action movies
Greg especially stuff we didn't see uh apparently
Demolition Man is the Taco Bell of lore according
to the comments on dread one so if there's
anything else in that vein do let us know and
uh we'll see you guys very soon and we appreciate
the patrons as ever we're getting into what month
is it August yeah getting into August so we're
back with more stuff very very soon much love
foreign